(whooshing)
- Initiate the action.
- Take action.
- Taking action.
- Do the action.
- Act Now!
- Took action.
- Hello Believe Vision, my
name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the
world's major problems.
So to help you in your journey today,
we're going to learn how to take action.
And also guys, if you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you
please leave it down
in the comments below,
put quotes around it,
you might win a prize.
But also when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- You speak to businesses and companies
and leadership teams
and employees and stuff.
Without mentioning names,
I don't want to put you on the spot but
have you gone and talked to a
company that's been in trouble
and then spoken to their team
and then checked in on them
after you've spoken to
their leadership team
and what did that look like,
did you notice a noticeable change?
Did they come to you and
tell you that this has helped
our organization out and our culture
is much improved because of it?
- You mean does my (bleep) work?
(audience laughing)
I mean.
Sure.
Here's the problem with my
stuff, you got to do it.
And I am not anybody's like
you know, mom or dad.
I'm not going to do it for you.
And I have a very laissez-faire approach.
I once had a client,
this is a bunch of years ago
that said, what guarantee do I have
that you're stuff will work?
To which my answer was,
none.
Like, I'm giving you a tool.
You can, it's like a hammer,
you can use it broadly or narrowly.
You can build a table,
you can build a house.
It's the same tool.
You can use it for marketing.
You can use it to completely
revitalize your entire culture.
And even though I'm going to sale you
the most beautiful hammer,
I'm not going to guarantee
the structural integrity of the house.
Right?
It's your business.
You want to ignore all my stuff.
Ignore it, I don't care.
And if your business collapses,
you know what happens to me?
Nothing.
Like, I don't mean to be cold about it.
Like of course, I want the
people I work with to do well
but it's not mine.
It's theirs and I take no
emotional responsibility
for the decisions they make.
So yes, there are many people
that I have had the pleasure
of working with.
Some who worked for
dysfunctional organizations
that went on the hard journey
of completely changing the way they lead
and completely revitalizing their culture
and it has great success.
It's not because of me,
it's because of them, right.
At the same time, there
are many people who came in
and they're like, what an
amazing speech and did nothing.
You know, thanks that was great, you know.
And I don't, of course, it's
going to fail, you know.
So, I think that we have too much,
especially in the consulting world,
or the design world,
everybody's so paternalistic about it.
And designers are famous for this right.
They get so personally
offended when the client
chooses the wrong thing.
Uh, such idiots!
Don't they know we're trying to help them?
(audience laughing)
Or who cares?
Like it's their freaking business, right.
That's what you find, I've had that.
Instead of arguing with somebody
for them to make the right choice,
'cause we genuinely want to help them.
What I have found is,
if you push the accountability on them,
'cause when we argue, we're
taking accountability.
This is better, this will help you.
We're taking responsibility,
accountability.
But if we say look,
we've been doing this a bunch of years.
We know more about design than you do.
I'm telling you, for every
reason that I can outline for you
why this will help you more.
But if you don't want
to do it, that's fine.
It's your business, do what you want.
The minute you switch the accountability
and put it all on them.
Amazingly, they're much
more open to your opinion.
(audience laughing)
Because now they're responsible.
- One night, Chris has gone to bed.
I'd been struggling,
struggling, struggling.
We still had all the same problems.
We struggled on the house,
still facing bankruptcy,
still fighting like crazy.
I was still unemployed.
They still hadn't figured
out like the solution yet
for the business.
And I was about to turn off the TV
and there on the TV
there was this rocket launching
and I thought oh my gosh.
That is it!
I am going to launch myself out of bed
like a rocket ship, like NASA!
Right here and launch me out of that bed.
And I'm going to move so fast
that I don't think.
- Hm.
- I'm going to beat my brain.
Now, here's a really interesting point.
I talk a lot about your
instincts and inner wisdom.
And we can get get into
this a little bit later
but a lot of us talk about the fact
that you have a gut feeling.
But what all this research
that I've done for the book
and all the speaking that I do,
what I've discovered that's fascinating
is actually when you set goals,
when you have an intention
on something that you want
to change about your life,
your brain helps you.
What it does it is opens up a checklist
and then your brain goes to work
trying to remind you.
- Yeah.
- Of that intention that you set.
And it's really important
to develop the skill
and I say that word purposefully.
The skill of knowing how
to hear that inner wisdom
and that intention kicking in.
And leaning into it quickly.
So for me, my brain saying that's it.
Right there.
Move as fast as a rocket, Mel.
I wanted to change to my life.
And I think most people that are miserable
or that are really like dying to be great
and dying to have more,
we want to change.
We want to live a better life.
We want to create more for our families.
We want to be happier.
The desire is there.
Again it's about how do you
go from knowledge to action
so the first thing in this
story that's important
is realizing that the answer was in me.
And my mind was telling me, pay attention.
Could have also been the bourbon.
(laughing)
I had a couple of Manhattan's that night.
Anyway, the next morning,
the alarm goes off and
I pretended NASA was there.
It's the stupidest story.
I literally went five,
four, three, two, one.
I counted out loud and then I stood up.
And I'll never forget standing there
in my bedroom.
It was dark, it was cold.
It was winter in Boston.
And for the first time in three months,
I had beaten my habit of
hitting the snooze button.
I couldn't believe it.
And I thought, wait a minute.
Counting backwards,
that is the dumbest thing I've ever heard
in my entire life.
Well the next morning, I
used it again it worked.
The next morning I used
it again and it worked.
And then I started to notice
something really interesting.
There were moments all day long.
All day long.
Just like that five second moment in bed.
Where I knew knowledge,
what I should do.
And if I didn't move within five seconds,
my brain would step in
and talk me out of it.
Every human being has
a five second window.
Might even be shorter for you.
You have about a five second window
in which you can move from idea to action
before your brain kicks into full gear
and sabotages any change in behavior.
'Cause remember your
brain is wired to stop you
from doing things that are comfortable
or uncertain or scary.
It's your job to learn how
to move from those ideas
that could change everything
into acting on them.
- People want to know
how to stop the laziness
and they want to know how to
stop the procrastination and
they have some idea in
their head, you know,
some kind of a vision
of what they want to do.
But they don't know where to start.
They don't know where
to start it, you know.
They don't know where to start.
And to this day, hey,
where do I start and when's
the best time to start.
And I have a very simple answer for that.
Here.
And now.
That's it.
You want to improve?
You want to get better?
You want to get on a workout
program or a clean diet?
You want to start a business?
You want to write a book or make a movie
or build a house or a computer
or put together some mobile application?
Where do you start?
You start right here.
And when do you start,
you start right now.
You initiate the action aggressively.
You go.
'Cause the idea isn't
going to execute itself.
And the book isn't going to write itself.
And the weights out in the gym,
they're not going to move themselves.
You have to do it and
you have to do it now.
And that means, you got
to stop thinking about it
and stop dreaming about it.
And stop researching every aspect of it.
And reading all about it.
And debating the pros and cons of it.
Just start doing it.
Take that first step.
And make it happen.
Get after it.
And get after it here and now.
- Take action.
Whatever you want to do you.
Whatever you're thinking about.
You will not get it until
you get take action.
Make that move.
Make it a small step.
If you want a house, go get
a rug, you know what I mean?
If you want a new car, go
get some car freshener.
Take action.
Make this thing happen for
you and it will happen.
Action, action, action.
You know one thing that
I can really attribute to every failure
in my life.
Whether it be personal, financial,
in any kind of way, business, whatever.
It's because of a lack
of my attempt to take action.
I did not take action.
And it kind of changed,
once I got the fact that
action is the key
it changed my life in many, many ways.
- I think stress,
you can be, I think one of the things
that's very important
to note about stress,
is that stress primarily
comes from not taking action
over something that you
can have some control over.
So, if I find that some particular thing
is causing me to have stress,
that's a warning flag for me.
What it means is,
there's something that I
haven't completely identified
perhaps in my conscious mind
that is bothering me and I haven't
yet taken any action on it.
I find as soon as I identify it
and make the first phone call
or send off the first email message
or whatever it is that we're going to do
to start to address that
situation, even if it's not solved,
the mere fact that we're addressing it,
dramatically reduces any
stress that might come from it.
So stress comes from ignoring things
that you shouldn't be ignoring,
I think in a large part.
So, stress doesn't come.
People get stress wrong all
the time, in my opinion.
Stress doesn't come from
hard work, for example.
You know, you can be
working incredibly hard
and loving it.
And likewise, you can be out of work
and incredibly stressed over that.
So, and likewise if you kind
of use that as an analogy
for what I was just talking about.
If you're out of work,
but you're going though, you know
a disciplined approach of you know,
a series of job interviews and so on
and working to remedy that situation,
you're going to be a lot less stressed
than if you're just worrying about it
and doing nothing.
- One of the functions of
belief is taking action.
We did a survey of about two thousand
top entrepreneurs and we
noticed that one of the things
that people who win in that
world have is a bias for action.
If they have an
inspiration, they act on it.
I mean how many of you
have ever had a great idea,
talked about it, thought about it,
didn't do it.
And then someone else
did it and was successful
and you went, darn I
should have done that.
Maybe it was buy that piece of property.
We all have that piece of
property we wished we bought.
You know.
(audience murmuring)
Anyway, so we're going to be looking at
the idea that taking action
is part of law of attraction.
See a lot of people think
you can just sit in your room
meditate, visualize
having the perfect car,
the perfect house, the
perfect relationship.
Then it'll kind of just come to you.
And I always say unless you
live at the bottom of a hill,
(audience laughing)
where there's a road,
there's probably not
going to be a Cadillac
show up in your living room, right.
(audience laughing)
So, think about this, the last six letters
of the word attraction spell what?
(audience murmuring)
A-C-T-I-O-N, action.
Now there's two kinds of
action that are critical.
There's obvious action.
If you want a certain kind of car,
you should go down and test drive it.
You should find out how much it costs.
You should see what it
costs to maintain it.
You should go, you know, spend,
I like to test drive a
car, three or four times.
Go down to the dealer, take a camera.
Stick my head out the
window, say a picture of me.
I'll be back to buy it, you know.
(audience laughing)
Put it up on my refrigerator.
Look at it very day.
Eventually, you know,
those kinds of things
produce a car, right.
Saving for it, so forth.
But there are also things
called inspired actions.
All of a sudden, you get an
inspiration to do something
and you didn't know what it was.
You don't have the sense of like,
how is this rationally going to make sense
for me to move forward in my life.
I'll give you an example.
A friend of mine, Dr. Ignatius Piazza,
graduates chiropractic school.
He wants to move Monterey
near Pebble Beach
where the golf course is.
And he gets there and he says
to the local Chiropractic Association,
I'd like to join you.
I'd like you to help me
get my practice started.
And they said, we don't
need any more chiropractics.
We have one chiropractic for
ever eight people in this area.
It's too many.
Now he could have say, okay,
let the external reality
control his internal experience
but he didn't do that.
He said, I'm going to think about this
and visualize it and believe in it.
And something will come that I will do.
And what came to him to do,
was to take six months
before he opened his office
and put a pin where he wanted his office
and then concentric circles,
knock on every door in every neighborhood
saying hi, I'm a new doctor in town.
Can I ask you a few questions?
You know I'm starting this practice.
Should I open from five
til nine in the morning
or should I be open from
five until nine at night
for people who have nine to five jobs.
Which would be better?
Should I advertise in
this paper or that paper?
Should I call it Ignatius
Piazza Chiropractic
or Chiropractic West?
Then his last question was
if I have an open house,
would you like to receive an invitation?
If they said yes, he wrote it down.
Now over six months, he
knocked on 12,500 doors.
Talked to 6,500 people and
gathered over 4000 names
of people who said yes,
I'd like an invitation
to your open house.
Now when he opened his
office six months later
in a town that did not
need another chiropractor
according to the professionals,
his first month in
practice he netted $72,000.
(audience murmuring)
In his first year in practice,
his gross income was
over a million dollars.
I was giving a talk and
mentioned this story
just about five years ago
and this happened about 25 years ago.
Someone said, he knocked on my door.
(audience laughing)
And he left his card.
And two years later, I
needed a chiropractor
and I called him.
Because we work with people we know,
we've had an experience with right?
So he trusted his intuition.
He took action on it.
Other people would say, oop,
guess I can't have what I want.
You got to be willing to take the action.
- You can't just wait
for inspiration, to act.
That's the biggest mistake people make.
Don't wait to be inspired
to do the action.
You have to do the action first
and then you'll be inspired.
So what I would do is I
would sit there and draw
the comic and I would come up with it.
But some days I come home
from school, sit down and go
I'm just going to wait for
the inspiration to hit me.
I'm going to wait for the
idea to come fully formed.
And when I got a joke,
then I'll go draw it.
And I would sit there for
maybe three or four hours
(laughing) and then go, alright screw it,
I got to get up, I got to do the process.
I got to sit there and just start drawing.
I don't even know why or
how I'm going to get there
and then two things would come together
and then it would be oh, there's an idea
oh there's the first para,
the second para.
And then it would come together.
Always, it would not take very long.
I would fight that process so much
because what was I doing.
I was waiting for
inspiration before I acted.
It's always the other way around.
Act first, then the inspiration will come.
Draw first.
Then the inspiration will come.
Just start shooting, then
the inspiration will come.
Just start moving, then
Don't wait.
So many people wait
or tell you they're
going to write this novel
or they're going to do this or
their going to make this film,
they never do it.
Because they're waiting for
all this stuff to come to them.
It comes through doing it.
- Don't wait.
Go.
Do it.
Act.
Now.
And really accepting, we need
you, we need you, we need you.
You are the one percent,
you're the percent that says
I'm going to wake up.
You're the light workers.
You are the ones that
have accepted this call
in this lifetime, at this time.
You have decided to wake
up and chosen to say
yes, I'm here to be of greater service
than just to feed myself, right.
I'm here to feed the world.
I'm here to give love.
I'm here to be an
expression of that truth.
Don't hold that back.
Don't play small.
We can't, we need you.
And so really if you
or anyone in this room
who has been sitting on that book idea
waiting a little bit longer
before you start that t-shirt training,
or doing ten more teacher trainings
before you actually teach.
(audience laughing)
If that's you guys,
start and the pressure will be off.
I can't begin to tell you, I
could cry just saying this,
the day I taught Ego Eradicator
I was two weeks into my teaching training
and I said F it, let's go!
And I just went and I
felt so much pressure off.
I felt so much lift.
Because I just knew I felt
this technology must be shared.
I can't hold it.
I can't keep it from myself.
I can't just sit in my
apartment by myself like this
(sniffing)
I got to give this.
(audience laughing)
And sharing it, the
pressure, it just lifted.
It was like, aw, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
And I wasn't the perfect teacher.
And I look back and I was
teaching Ego Eradicator wrong.
Everyone's arms were like this.
Everyone was breathing backwards.
It was a mess but I did it.
And I started.
And in those moments
when we just get to go,
just go.
The pressure is off
and then we clear the
path and we are guided
to the next right action.
And that is the most magnificent
thing you can do right now.
- I find it quite inspiring.
You were in film publicity, originally.
And then at a certain point,
you decided that you wanted to direct.
Can you tell us how you
got from there to here?
- Well I was one of those
ladies standing on the side.
You know, and they work hard.
And no one ever really
gives them the shout out.
I thank you all, the publicist
in the corner, you know.
(audience clapping)
And as a person who loved
film and wanted to make film,
you're standing there
supporting film makers,
telling their stories and it's
something that I love doing.
But for me there was always a
little bit of, I don't know, not jealousy,
but just like wow, that's
great what they're doing.
And so at the moment, when I actually
started to write and tried
to direct my own stuff,
I was still doing publicity
for other people's films.
I was trying to make my own films.
I was asking for
permission, pitching people,
trying to get contacts and network
and do all the things that don't matter.
Because the only thing
that matters is your work.
And so, when I finally realized that
and started to make small things and try
to move them around festivals
and just you know, just share my work,
the energy behind that positive intention
started the ball rolling.
And I've only been making
films for five years.
And I only quit my job
full-time three years ago.
Because I was still
holding on to publicity
as a security blanket.
And so yeah,
you know, I look at
each year that's passed
and all I've tried to do is continue
to make work whether I have the money
to make a film, a narrative, a doc,
a commercial, a TV show,
directed an episode of Scandal,
(audience clapping)
a documentary about Venus Williams,
whatever I, a story I want to
tell through whatever medium,
short medium, TV medium,
commercial medium,
full-length, documentary,
feature, that's something that
I really learned from Spike.
Lee, not Jones, I'm
sure Jones is nice but.
(audience laughing)
I was talking to a lady, she
was like Spike Jones is a.
No lady, Spike Lee.
(audience laughing)
But you know, remember he
did commercials with Jordan.
He's done almost as many
docs as he's done narratives.
He's made a film every
year for the past 20 years.
I mean, he's really the blue print of
just not even a black film maker,
a film maker who has just
continued to make work.
And so that's how we're here now.
- Your book is titled, Nothing
to Lose, Everything to Gain.
What does that title mean to you?
- You know it's a mindset.
So, it's a mindset that I had
when I was on the streets,
and when I lived in boys homes
and when I was in juvenile hall.
And the essence is, when
you have nothing to lose,
you either are backed into a corner or,
and you cower and you submit
or you fight your way out
and so, I've been backed
into a corner a few times
both when I was a kid but then also
in my professional career
when I decided to become an entreprenuer.
When the recession hit, you know,
I had to apply that same mindset.
- Now as your mantra, why do you think
so many people don't live
with that mindset today?
I mean, there's a lot of fear out there.
Fear of the unknown.
- Yeah, you know what, fear is a trap.
And people are domesticated so to speak.
So, you know, they're comfortable.
And if they just realize that
they have nothing to lose,
you know, these middle
class folks that are,
you know, they think they
have something to lose.
They think that they're
reputation with their neighbors
or their credit or their
Louis Vuitton luggage,
or whatever it is
is worth holding on to.
If they just ventured out there,
started a business, took action,
they'd realize there's a better life.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoy.
I love to know what did
you take from this video
that you're going to
immediately apply somehow
to your life or to your business.
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really excited to
see what you have to say.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is,
much love.
I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)